why have we still got no announcement
about the Orville is it going to return
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
well I've told you a few times now that
I'm pretty confidently awful is going to
return and that actually there have been
negotiations and that's been confirmed
by a few of the actors from the series
even Seth MacFarlane himself that
conversations have been going on but
there's no decision been made now I've
told you a few times exclusively and
first that there were negotiations
regarding the Orville but they wanted to
bring it in at a much smaller budget
than Horizons the third season of the
Orville New Horizons cost a bloody
fortune and even though it was a very
popular for Disney and Hulu it maybe
wasn't as popular as they were hoping so
even though they would love to bring the
show back it does have to have a more
appropriate budget now that has been
negotiated and apparently I'm told they
have an agreement between Seth
MacFarlane and Hulu Disney and for what
that show would look like for how much
it would cost and for when they would
like to do it so why hasn't been any
announcement well the real reason is
twofold for one Seth MacFarlane is very
very busy
as a writer he has a few upcoming
projects five in fact he's doing the
Ted's TV series he's doing the
screenplay and story for the new Naked
Gun movie starring Liam Neeson he's
doing the wins of War screenplay he's
still working on Family Guy obviously
and he's got something called the
shrouded college that he's working on so
very busy guy he's also an actor
go back to IMDb he's also got
he's obviously also a producer he
produces all these things and he's also
an actor with two upcoming projects he's
going to be um in
apparently he's going to be in Star Wars
detours as Emperor Palpatine which is a
cartoon series and he is going to appear
in Ted
so
busy busy man lots of work to do
but there is another big reason why we
actually haven't had an announcement of
this project
the right to strike so there is a writer
strike coming up if your regular side
strike you'll know I've talked about
this in a couple of videos in the last
week talking about how this is holding
up lots of projects it's holding up
Babylon five it's potentially holding up
Stargate it's holding up a million other
things to be honest so we don't even
know about
the reason is because production
companies and studios are focusing on
the things that are already in
production they want to get all of the
scripts written they want to get
everything done so that if there is a
right to strike they can continue
filming that it's not going to basically
mean that Hollywood has to stop
now what you have to realize is back in
the day when they used to do 22 Episodes
you know series for everything
everything was on networks and
everything was massive a lot of the
writing continued on throughout the
seasons you know Star Trek the Next
Generation for example they were they
were tapping away writing and then
literally throwing the scripts out and
they were filming the next day they
would that was how how it worked Babylon
5 was the same I've seen J Michael
suglinski talk about this repeatedly
about how he was basically writing one
day and literally filming the next it
was the wild west of how to make a TV
series
that doesn't happen anymore scripts are
developed they're agreed by Executives
they developed them over at long periods
of time they rewrite and rewrite and
then they film now the problem for
Stephanie McFarlane is he writes a lot
of his stuff
but is a member of the writer's Guild of
America so he's going to have to go on
strike
now you cannot announce that the Orville
is coming if you have no idea when
you're going to be able to make it so
they could release a statement to say
look we really really want to do season
four of the Orville but we have no idea
when
the same problem really is for Stargate
at the moment that they want to announce
this but can't now we're hoping that
we're going to get an announcement of
Stargate at July in San Diego Comic-Con
because hopefully by then the strike if
it even happens will be resolved
the last one lasted nearly four months
by the way
God if that happens again so simply put
that's why we have no announcement of
the Orville because they've got no idea
when they'd be able to make it
now there are a lot of rumors going
around that actually Disney are in
massive Financial issues Hulu they're
supposed to be buying Hulu which is just
going to add to those massive Financial
issues
and that actually a lot of writers in
Hollywood at the moment believe that
actually producers and Studios want the
strike to go ahead because it'll give
them an excuse to actually cancel lots
of projects that the studios don't want
to make or can't really afford to make
could the Orville fall in that category
well if Disney or Hulu were to announce
tomorrow there will not be a fourth
series of the Orville it will upset Seth
MacFarlane he loves that show he always
wanted to make Star Trek serious they
wouldn't let him so he made his own he
very clearly and very desperately wants
to make this series the fans would also
go freaking crazy because this is one of
those shows that people that are when
they are fans of it adore it there are
plans to make Galaxy Quest TV series and
I would argue why bother the Orville
already exists
so other Studios know how brilliant this
sort of show is and how successful it
can be but if the studio have their
doubts which I think it's fair to say
they probably do because they haven't
announced it already
or if they think actually you know what
we would rather Seth MacFarlane focused
on other things like Ted that will be
more popular that will have maybe a
wider popularity
this would give them the perfect excuse
to do that if the strike goes ahead so
they would be saving face the fans
they can blame the writers the fans
can't get too angry and probably more
importantly they can say to Seth
MacFarlane look because of the strike we
can't go ahead we wanted to but
too long has gone by now
maybe some of the actors will have moved
on we also know that actually a lot of
the actors contracts ended at the end of
season three that's quite common when
they do a series like this that actually
the actors have to sign up just for
three seasons initially so that's going
to be more expense for Hulu and Disney
as well because they've got to sign all
these axes up to contracts again but
actually on Twitter Etc a lot of the
actors say that ain't a problem I want
to come back and to be honest you just
rewrite things Seth McConnell will just
bring in new characters it's a
ship-based show isn't it people get
transferred off and transferred in all
the time you just change things up
so again that's not really an excuse
that they could use I just wonder if
Hulu and Disney actually did get the
opportunity to get out of making the
Orville though and they could do it
without upsetting Seth MacFarlane they
might take it but guys what do you think
do you think as soon as this writer's
strike thing is all resolved that we're
going to get an announcement about the
Orville I'm 50 50.
do you actually think though and do you
believe that the writer's strike could
be used as a tool by the evil Executives
that like for legal purposes have to say
that's allegedly evil
would use this excuse to cancel lots of
projects so that they and then they
would just simply blame the righteous
for it
I think probably
but guys again for the comments and tell
me exactly what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can go over to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you get to
see it without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign